hey guys you ready to go do a little
camping
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys we're here at the harker
island ferry in north carolina and we
are going to take a boat out there to
cape lookout national seashore it's a
beautiful uninhabited island it's a
national park and we're going to go and
camp
fish and ride atv all over the island
[Music]
so this is shackleford banks the first
stop of the ferry ride apparently
there's a lot of wild horses here
but uh it's not our stop
[Music]
thank you very much
all right guys welcome to cape lookout
national seashore me and the boys gonna
be doing a little bit of camping and
they also rent utvs here check this out
crazy thing about is it's super cheap
most places to run a utv like that five
six hundred bucks a day i think it's
like 120 or something like that it's
really affordable compared to most
places this is also supposed to be a
really great place to collect shells and
uh check it out all the different shells
you can find
oh
okay you go ahead and load your stuff up
here you go jake
hop on in
oh yeah that's diesel baby
[Music]
there's the cape lookout lighthouse
and the light keepers house
it looks like it's locked
[Music]
don't come by the trip with your tail
because then you'll bite you
he's on me
with a pokey face
you want him on your head
he's on you
i'm getting a little hungry let's go
find a campsite and then we can go make
lunch
jake do you like this
look at that one you found those already
that's awesome this is diesel-powered
beachcombing
[Music]
[Music]
it's a sea turtle egg you guys look at
this
look what i found
oh it is
oh that was zombo's oh watch out
i just saw some dolphins
[Music]
look at this guy
it's a starfish yeah he's alive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
look at that show
[Music]
oh look at this one
oh
[Music]
here what do you think about this spot
yeah this looks like a good spot to camp
nice little flat sheltered spot out of
the wind i think this is our spot
everyone
you guys ready for lunch
this is barbecued chicken everyone's
hungry so we're eating an mre for lunch
today you guys want some crackers and
jelly
okay
there you go grape jelly
oh baby
okay who wants the barbecue chicken who
wants rice
hey nathan do you like the rice
well the boys are getting a little antsy
and they want to ride around the utv a
little bit more okay
what'd you find coconut you got a
coconut
[Music]
look at this what's all this stuff up
here
oh
hop on in boys
mom's appetite for seashells is
insatiable we must find more shells
nice good job buddy
oh
[Music]
picking up a lot of driftwood for a good
campfire tonight
i did a fire starter review video a
little while ago and i fell in love with
these little zips fire starters
keep one or two in my bag just in case
these things go
you just can't smother them or put them
out
well it's four o'clock the sun's
starting to get a little bit low
hopefully the fishing will turn on here
a bit you guys want to try and catch a
shark or a stingray tonight
i'm gonna leave those rods up for a
little bit and see what happens jacob's
falling asleep in the utv i gotta go
wake him up
nathan's just sitting here chilling and
playing in the sand
okay buddy
here's your cup of noodles it's really
hot
you're good
let's go and eat some of that
all right got a little bit of curry and
rice
hey jacob you like your lasagna
well the fishing was a bit of a bust but
dinner was a success the kids are having
a good time they're playing dinosaur
attack uh in and around the utv right
now so they're happy what more can we
ask for
[Music]
you are so sad you know i'm gonna have
to wash you off
guys i got a fish
see if you can reel em in
oh yep
that's a big angry stingray
look at the barb on that thing
no i'm not going to kill him
i was just complaining how the fishing
wasn't doing anything in bulgaria caught
a stingray that means not skunked you
both want marshmallows in your hot
chocolate
here it is it's very hot though okay
you like that jacob are you having fun
yeah
i've got a thermos full of hot chocolate
too you guys drink as much hot chocolate
as you want
hey jacob what happened
did you try to poop
yeah
but you got all over
yeah that that happened
jake's an absolute little champ at potty
training but he tried to go off and poop
behind the sand dudes without telling me
he's gotten his pants down and pooped
all down the back of his pants and uh
anyway so i just spent the last 30 40
minutes cleaning poo off of everything
so
we're gonna kind of get the kids ready
for bed it's kind of a sign that it's
time to get in the tent and
wind it down
well it's dark but it's still a couple
hours before the boy's bedtime so uh
we're gonna take it easy and watch some
shows on the phone and just kind of hang
out a little bit
well i just found a mosquito that's been
feasting
it was a crazy night last night we had a
rainstorm come in around 11 until about
4 a.m and we had thunder and lightning
at 25 miles per hour winds it was
shaking things really aggressively and
it just
poured and we got a leak somewhere up in
here one of the first drops went right
in my ear
me up but thankfully it stopped so we
don't have to get packed up in the
driving raid
you guys sleep okay
do you wake up and hear the rainstorm
no you guys are out like a light so we
have a little hash browns a little
breakfast mre
all right we got the heater sleeve this
time
cracker dehydrated granola with
blueberries nice
cheese spread dry roasted peanuts a
pastry orange drink mix you just want to
play cracker
the pop tart
i i hate it when it rains like this
right at the end of a camping trip you
have to dry all your gear out really
thoroughly before you put it away
otherwise you'll get bad mildew so
everything i'm packing i'm just going to
take it home and i've got to unpack it
set it up in my basement and dry it out
oh it's such a pain
oh you can see how much standing water i
had under my mat everything's so wet and
sandy i'm just gonna chuck it all into
my bag
and pull out wash it and dry it when we
get home
oh wind blew my rods over and got sand
and all the reels that's that's awesome
oh
this is a really unique and gorgeous
place
this island is big and there's so many
miles and miles of beaches and trails we
drove 45 minutes that direction and
didn't get halfway across the island
oh that was a good camping site
[Music]
oh here on the southern part of the
island there's a lot of trucks and
campers on the island they get here by a
different ferry that goes out of davis
north carolina you get a national park
service off-road permit and you pay
about 100 bucks for the ferry and you
can take your truck over it's actually a
pretty cheap beach vacation you bring
your camper and your family stay for a
few days not bad at all
[Music]
it's a pretty little one a lot of people
come to this island but because there's
just so many miles the beach and because
you can camp anywhere it really feels
like you're out in the middle of nowhere
it's it's really really nice
look at this one
well we're back at the docks and we
returned the utv now we're just waiting
for the first ferry to arrive
take us back home have you guys like
this yes
i can see the ferry we're just dropping
some people off over there at
shackleford banks if you want to camp on
a remote island with even fewer crowds
and you don't want to bother with atvs
shackled for banks is a good place to go
dolphin right out there oh look at that
right there
well hopefully you guys at home enjoyed
watching this as much as we enjoyed
making it if you want to see more
camping videos from the outdoor boys
youtube channel don't forget to check
out our camping and adventure playlist
i'll put a link down in the video
description below also put links to the
ferry and the national park and all that
stuff so you guys can come here and do
this too and if you want to see more
videos like this don't forget to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
saturday morning thanks for watching
guys
nailed it if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor boys
youtube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every saturday
morning and hit that bell button you'll
get notifications thanks for watching
[Music]